foreign
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where
that is Dom Cash's king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships my co-host
today Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author we will
be answering your questions about your
life and your money thank you for
jumping in America the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jeff is going to start
us off this hour in Cincinnati hi Jeff
how are you
hey I'm I'm doing good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up foreign
well um I'm kind of a new follower I
just found you earlier this year I had
some questions about potentially
refinancing uh our house
we originally bought it back in January
of 2021.
um this is obviously before we knew you
and we we got a 30-year loan at two and
a half percent
um
and now kind of considering do we do we
move to a 15-year but my biggest concern
with that is that we're giving up that
two and a half percent rate to go
somewhere around five percent or so
you're right I would not do that you're
right
keep the existing mortgage you have if
you calculate a 30-year mortgage and you
calculate a 15-year mortgage at the same
interest rate in your case two and a
half and you pay the difference
like you like you took out of 30 and you
pay the extra amount as in the
difference between a 15 payment and a 30
payment it will pay off in exactly 15
years
okay you do not have to refinance to pay
a loan off in 15 years you just have to
pay it like it's a 15-year payment and
it'll pay right out or more of course
and then it would pay out even sooner so
never refinance just to move from a 30
to a 15. uh because you take on the
closing costs at a minimum and in this
case you'd go up in interest rate so you
never do that just pay extra on it and
you'll get there
okay
um that was easy wasn't it as far as
as far as how much
we're well within the
um 25 kind of calculating it off of two
and a half percent rate that we have
great
um but with rates now I know we're not
refinancing
um but that would obviously put us
probably closer to the 30 Mark do we
have well it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you're fine you know the reality
is your house payment is a fourth of
your take-home pay at a 15 year on two
and a half and so you're fine the reason
we put that in place is not to keep
people from buying homes and John people
are really mad right now about because
you hate homes house prices apparently I
hate home ownership and I'm an
unrealistic old
um Boomer or whatever other terms of
derision you can throw up my bald head
but the um I don't care if you get a
house you can't afford it doesn't affect
me it affects you if you buy a house you
can't afford Jeff's in good shape he's
not got any issues but
here's the thing and I've been answering
this question the same way for 30 years
like we have people call us from
California well Dave you're you know you
can't buy a house in California for that
uh that means you can't buy you can't
buy a house that's California for that
that's what that means you also may not
be able to buy a Bentley uh you also may
not be when I grew up this County that
we live in is the 11th wealthiest County
in the nation the wealthiest County in
Tennessee Williamson County Tennessee
where you and I are sitting right now
where both of us live now when I was
growing up that's where the rich people
lived and we said stuff like you can't
afford to live there and you know what
not everybody can afford to live there
you know everybody can afford to live on
Rodeo Drive or in downtown Manhattan or
downtown Tokyo or downtown London it's
freaking expensive and so sometimes you
just have to say I can't afford it
number one but number two here the
reason for this is we know from the data
of doing the 30 years that you're most
likely way to become wealthy is to get
your home paid off as soon as possible
in all other debts too because it frees
up your most powerful wealth building
tool and so if you keep a mortgage
around like it's a pet for your whole
life because you're thinking well I'm
always going to have a mortgage and the
only way I can afford a mortgage the
only way I'm ever going to get a house
because I'll never get a house I'll
never get a house I'm so stuck and it's
just not fair and life's not fair and
I'm a four-year-old on the cereal aisle
throw in a fit and I want Captain Crunch
yeah blame it you know and it's just
like and you just everybody's acting
like that right now and so I'm sorry you
I'm I'm sorry that when I was a kid I
couldn't live in Williamson County I
couldn't afford it my family didn't make
that kind of money I'm sorry I had a
traumatized childhood I'm sorry but it's
the way life is and so you know the
answer is no the reason you tell
yourself no is so you can tell yourself
yes later so if you go buy a house you
can't afford and you go take car
payments out that you can't afford and
you go take which nobody can you go take
out a student loan and you go take out
MasterCard and visa and American
distress you're going to be normal and
normal is you work your whole life and
give all of the money you earn to
someone else in the form of payments and
retire broke and hope social insecurity
will take care of you who the crap wants
to be normal right
and so you've got to break this cycle
and not be angry
at me or at the world or at Instagram or
Twitter or whatever it is you're angry
at this week
um because house prices went up I'm
really sorry I I don't want you to be
upset and I don't want you to not have a
house but also don't want you to do
something stupid that's going to keep
you broke your whole life I'll throw a
third one on there Dave
I have found in my life when I've had a
30-year mortgage and I've had a couple
of those in the 15 year
I can have all the best intentions with
a 30-year mortgage
but when it comes down to it every
single month somebody invites me out to
a thing or hey we're all going out to
this thing and whether I've got the best
intentions or I've got all the willpower
in the world it's really hard for me to
make that to double that payment or to
make that Gap payment between the
30-year note is is requiring me to pay
and what I could be paying for that 15
year
with the 15-year I'm locked into it I
gotta do it one of the things I figured
out when I very first started doing this
stuff with Financial Peace when I
started studying rich people is they put
smart things on autopilot yes I don't
want to think about it a hundred percent
of the 15-year mortgages pay off in 15
years or less 100 or they get foreclosed
on I mean 100 of them do okay people
that take out a 30 promising to pay a 15
the studies say 92 percent do not stick
with the schedule if you if you put a
system in place that you have to be in
the top eight percent is the only way
you win you lose you're gonna that's
dumb I just was listening to some
obesity researchers today and they were
talking about step one create an
environment where you can at least
attempt to be successful get the junk
out of your house yeah right you can't
have it all there and say I'm going to
make good choices because you're not
going to make a choice James Claire
talks about that in atomic habits yeah
talks about the exact same thing what is
it you're trying to create a habit then
don't put stuff that's contrary to The
Habit right in front of you the opposite
of paying the mortgage off early another
autopilot is the 401ks that's why
they're so successful you never see the
money it just comes out your check
automatically or an auto draft on your
checking account for your Roth IRAs or
your kids 529 you Autumn you're an
automatic investor and David Bach may
had a best-selling book the automatic
millionaire or whatever it was called
and he said just put everything on
automatic and you know what there's
something to that and so quit do quit
thinking you're like have superpowers
just to get to buy crap you can't afford
it's a bad idea
[Music]
thank you
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five one of the things we are doing
today and this week is we're talking
about the importance of insurance the
subject no one likes to talk about
everybody say it with me Insurance sucks
until you need it right and then it
doesn't and then when you got it and you
need it it's like the right kind and you
did the right thing but it's confusing
too many people buy the wrong stuff they
spend the wrong money on the wrong
things but insurance is a huge blessing
because people that build wealth not
only play offense they also play defense
and insurance is the defense side and so
in honor of uh this insurance week here
we're talking about the confidence in
your coverage program that George
Campbell put out uh with our Ramsay
trusted people and all the stuff details
on your insurance it's really good stuff
Donna is on the line Donna's in
Pensacola Florida so Donna talk about
insurance and the importance of it in
your life
Donna
Donna I'm here can you hear me yes ma'am
hey how are you I'm good how are you
today good talk about insurance and the
importance of it in your situation
so I wanted to speak specifically to
insurance and life insurance with second
marriages
there's a lot of people out there with
second marriages and it adds in some
factors that maybe you hadn't thought
about before so what happened in my
situation was my husband passed away two
years ago and when I contacted the
um department at his work for life
insurance it turns out they never got
his change of beneficiary form
so when we both got married we both
filled out the change of beneficiary
forms and we sent them in and apparently
they got mine and didn't get hit so all
of his life insurance went to his
ex-wife who you know hated him and
didn't want to have anything to do with
him and so we had no idea if we were
married for three years we had no idea
that they never received that document
and we could have known we could have
known because they send you back a copy
that they received it we never followed
up to check on it
um another thing that happened was you
get when you retire or die you get paid
for your unused vacation time and unused
sickly
one of they're considered separate leave
and one of them has a beneficiary form
and the other one does it well he had
worked there for 30 years so you know
back when he was 18 he had signed a
beneficiary form for whichever one has
one and totally forgot that that even
existed
because it's not like a huge amount of
money like life insurances so it turns
out he didn't change that beneficiary
form so it went to somebody else and
then I got the other one like his
parents or something or
no he he was married for a short time
back when he was 18 so it probably went
back to that wife oh my gosh okay
um yeah and then the ex-wife's got money
well I got the tsp but uh the life
insurance I think was higher at that
point in time
um
and another thing that I came across and
I don't know which this is from I don't
know if it's from his military time or
from a life insurance policy or what it
was from but there was somebody who
before they would distribute funds I had
to come up with the marriage dates and
divorce dates of the previous spouses
hmm so he'd been married a short time
when he was very young when he was in
the military and then he'd been married
for a long time for a second marriage
and I was the third so
I looked through all his forms and I
found all that and had it but I I called
up you know people that I knew that were
on a second marriage I'm like I guess
because they were trying they were
trying to prove that he wasn't married
to more than one person
yes they wanted to make sure that he
really was divorced from previous
marriages
yeah so those are all things that I'm
recommending that people look into don't
just assume you've got all your details
in order
um I mean so when you went through the
confidence in your coverage series is
that the kind of thing that jumped out
to you or did you pick up something else
uh the thing that jumped out to me in
that because I had been uh I had been
listening intently and for a few years
and so I had you know background on
almost everything but one thing that
jumped out to me in the little
questionnaire that you take yourself was
about long-term care insurance and I'm
57 so I'm not 60 yet but it caused me to
check into it because I have a diagnosis
that I thought might make me ineligible
and it did so it just
um it's it's a kidney disease it doesn't
affect my life I'm totally healthy I
just have to get my blood checked every
year to make sure it isn't progressing
so I don't think about it a lot but it's
enough to make me ineligible for
long-term care insurance I wouldn't be
able to get life insurance now things
like that that if you get a diagnosis
and I've had the diagnosis for 20 years
so if you get it when you're younger and
you find out you're ineligible later for
these things you need to go ahead and
build up your nest egg and be prepared
for those kinds of expenses it for real
for real so it sounds like what you're
you're mentioning here is it goes back
to one word that I just keep hearing
over and over as you're talking and
that's this idea of
being highly intentional
about the hard conversations there is a
chance no matter how small
um that something may happen to one of
you and we need to make sure all of our
ducks in a row and we need to make that
extra phone call at work sit down with
our insurance agent and make sure we're
covered make sure these things are in
order so that if the unthinkable happens
which in your case it did we're covered
everybody's on the same page he was 49
when he drowned in the Gulf of Mexico
another thing to think about is the
relationship your spouse has with your
own kid because you need to think when
you get married a second time you need
to think okay yes we are our life
insurance policies are merits they say
the same thing everything will go to our
kids but
if you die at the same time if one of
you dies first and the person who
survives doesn't have a relationship
with your kid and everything is going to
your spouse that you love and you chose
and then and then later on they die
everything goes to their kids and your
kids get nothing
you might want some stuff to go to your
kids when you die because your spouse
may live longer and your spouse May
marry somebody else
and then they go again you don't even
know gets everything and then your your
kids and your spouse's kids don't get
any of it
so it gets super complicated to do a
will and to do the beneficiaries and
everything yeah right and thinking
through not necessarily the first
movement the first Rhythm if something
happens but the second one is the one
that's hard to anticipate yeah yeah
because all the beneficiary forms I've
seen say if you fill this out then boom
that person gets it whatever you want
happens if you don't fill it out then
the system has to go through the process
of figuring out who really gets it and
if it's your first marriage it's going
to be the spouse if your second marriage
holy cow you have no idea what's going
to happen yeah yeah wow that's good
inside Donna thank you for sharing all
that wow pretty important crazy crazy
stuff
well you can uh go to ramsesolutions.com
and check out the confidence in your
coverage series there is a five-part
series there they're all very short
they're all very fun and funny because
it is George Campbell after all and um
ramseysolutions.com confidence it is a
free five-day video guide to walk you
through the different kinds of insurance
and Donna's insights are really really
valuable there
um and you know the the thing is John
these aren't things right doing a will
making sure your beneficiary is the
right making sure the name on your
mutual fund account has changed uh all
those kinds of things are um
none of this is like
sit down have fun no this is not like I
get to do the most fun thing this
weekend I'm working on this crap right
but um but it you know when you've got
all that in order that is one way you
are saying to your wife your husband
your kids I love you I love you even
when I'm not here I love you yeah it's
it's that level of diligence and by the
way it is the difference in poor people
and rich people often
wealthy people do this kind of stuff
uh people who won't have any money
doesn't matter well it's
kind of a correlation there you know do
the do the intentional diligent thing
take care of the little things and the
big things tend to take care of
themselves
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney number one best-selling
author and Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions a whole bunch of folks
visiting us today thank you for visiting
us guys by the way if you're ever in the
Franklin Tennessee south of Nashville
area and want to stop by it is a free
visit to the Ramsey
complex including the visitor center
here in the lobby and you can watch the
show we taped the show every day from
one to four or we do the show live is
also simultaneously taped from one to
four
Central every day and in the middle of
that Lobby is the debt free stage on
that stage is Jonathan and Amy hey guys
how are you good how are you good
welcome where do you guys live
um Watkins Glen New York all right cool
welcome to Nashville how much debt have
you paid off a hundred and two thousand
all right how long did this take four
years good for you and your range of
income during that time uh 60 to 75 000.
cool what do you all do for a living I'm
a teaching assistant I was a vehicle
purchaser for a scrap yard and I
currently am a teaching assistant now oh
okay both of you good good for you cool
so what kind of debt was the 102 000.
a lot of things it was credit card debt
personal loans family loans uh we owed
some Library money like we own we own
everything the library we just want one
of those dreams you have in the middle
of the night that you forgot from 30
years ago when you're in hockey to the
library that's knowing you're not you're
not doing well it's pretty bad it's
actually really bad when you don't have
money to buy a coffee and then you're
like let's just transfer money over and
yeah it's cool like it's all good so
you're normal pretty normal yeah
normal's no fun and you decide to change
four years ago what caused you to do
this Ramsey stuff tell us the story well
so our church was doing a
Ramsey yeah Financial be sure thank you
I'm sorry I'm really nervous there's no
trouble but um so I mean really they
were the Catalyst higher hope um in Big
Flats New York was like the huge
Catalyst to it I thought we were fine
honest to God I just thought credit
cards were just normal and we pay them
when we can
when we want to exactly
um so my husband was super nerdy and
really wanted to get into this and I was
very reluctant and I said let's just try
it like let's look at everything kind of
try it it was a little ramsay-ish
through the course I was kicking and
screaming oh okay
um but then I really got on board
especially when we started seeing the
little ones it was so big for us
um he was a great big support I mean he
kind of just
I don't know the whole time you were
just not harsh but like kind of real but
it was really good like I don't know we
just and we saw our girls kind of
prospering I had never seen money talk
um he had neither but the girls I mean
they play your show every Saturday on
Alexa they say Alexa play the Ramsay
show and we listen to it so it's I mean
that's our why that's a huge why very
cool it's awesome so and they love
knowing that they can plan for the
future I mean and they're seven and ten
so I love it it's awesome it's very good
so you kicked and screamed all the way
through the course up until the last one
or all the way through and I'm really I
hate won you over simply by causing the
the money to start winning
okay so I would say it was about two
weeks and we started making friends and
we went through a live course so it was
really nice to see other people kind of
going through the same struggles
um and the same kind of I don't
entertained her moments that I had takes
some of the shame away from the process
it does yeah
um y'all going through the same thing
yeah and then we actually like I don't
know about 3n
um I kind of it all clicked and we were
starting to pay off more and it was
doing really good and we had our
emergency fund and it was really yeah
and then we taught it at our church oh
wow you went all the way we did it was
Full Circle but I kind of hoped I like
let the shame like my hair straightener
broke one time and I was like guys I'm
not buying it it's not my budget so this
is what you have to look at this week
I'm really sorry and you should hold on
this is important and you survived I did
hey more importantly did the rods and
cones in there did they survive too yeah
everything was great everything was
great wow yeah it felt like weird to be
weird but it feels even better now to be
weird so so Jonathan what was it like
Dragon like a hurricane through this
process
it wasn't that bad we were we were
together but she just had struggles
tonight
it was good
well done you guys all right so what do
you tell people now that your
coordinators now that you paid off 102
000 your actual professionals now what
do you tell them the key to getting out
of debt is
not doing the budget just got to start
somewhere and that's huge it's huge it
is your guideline it's your everything I
mean it's neither one or the other
telling each other you can't do it it's
literally there on paper so I mean Amy's
talking like a real free spirit but a
real free spirit who had a vote
you had you had control in this you
weren't enough John the one telling you
what to do both of you are voting and
you're agreeing in like two grown-ups
this is where we're going and this is
the price we're gonna pay if you live
like no one else later you can live and
give like no one else absolutely and you
said something powerful you shift the
blame to this piece of paper and so I
don't hate Jonathan for saying no
yeah the budget said the budget said yes
it was the budget what was your what was
your favorite uh altercation
what was the biggest fight the biggest
fight you had
okay so he remembers his but you go
ahead and answer
okay so you have your fun money and I
decided to grow my fund money by selling
like thrifted items and stuff and my
husband said well you can't do that your
fun money it can't grow because you've
got to pay off your debt and or our debt
together and she wanted to take her
money and like invest it and then keep
her extra money oh I know yeah yeah I
got the program here it was a Kicking
and Screaming moment in the very
beginning you have to give some Grace I
love it
so yeah that was that was big Jonathan
yeah you guys you're perfect for each
other I mean y'all like you make his
life fun that's great I mean and he
makes sure there's water coming out of
the faucet every month
that's true you guys got us down you
guys are all right this is a perfect
y'all are perfect couple this is great
so well done I'm so proud of y'all thank
you how's it feeling to be free it feels
amazing awesome our marriage is way
better than anything I could have
imagined that's why I could take the
different job to as a job switch because
I've been the same job for 12 years and
then we got that free like we can make
some choices he's going back to school
um to be a teacher so oh good you know
he's living out his dream too and that's
really cool that's very cool that's
incredible and that wasn't going to
happen as long as you just kept swimming
in credit card debt no way yeah there's
no way you guys are powerful well done
thank you for going to be a teacher man
yeah amen thank you man we need good
people teaching he's pretty good at
being a ta so he'll be a really good
teacher amen good stuff all right you
brought the kiddos with you what are
their names and ages
um Eliza is 10. and Marlena is seven all
right very good well we've got a copy of
the baby baby steps millionaires book
for you because that's the next chapter
in your story for sure I mean from
kicking and screaming to coordinating
we're going all the way through the
whole thing I like it that's that's the
best kind right there and we've also got
a copy of Total Money Makeover for you
to give to somebody in one of your
classes and we'll give you a one-year
subscription to Financial Peace
University you can find somebody that
needs to go through the class when
you're leading it and help them out
doing that thank you of course that
comes with the every dollar premium and
this is the brand new lessons that just
came out awesome brand new videos just
came out so make sure you're jumping in
there and getting all that done when
you're coordinating good stuff thank you
guys so much you're incredible I'm so
proud of you rock stars thank you well
Heroes took care of your life man
Jonathan Amy Eliza and Marlena Watkins
Glen New York 102 000 paid off in four
years making 60 to 75 000 counted down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
[Music]
answer
[Applause]
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
powerful
powerful good stuff
good stuff grown-ups being grown-ups
it's a good thing in America raising
grown-ups yeah raising another batch of
grown-ups that's really good this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442 Ram or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today Sierra is with us in Portland
Oregon hi Sierra welcome to the Ramsay
show
hello thanks for having me sure what's
up um we just completed baby steps two
through four and we have approached baby
steps five but my husband and I have a
disagreement um
when it comes to saving for your kids
college fund um I'm all for it and my
husband is against it
against
saving for your kids
yes he does not think he should pay for
his kids college or anything having to
do with it
correct how come
uh so we both went to college got our
bachelor's degree my husband about four
years ago ended his career and switched
into a trade
um the trade by far in two years he was
making what he was making doing his
college career job and
he thinks that college is like a waste
of money now that he's been in a trade
and he also believes that my son or our
son I should say sorry
um will appreciate money more which I
disagree if he has to pay for himself so
um and also in addition
I don't know how long it will be but the
union has started a program where they
pay 100 of the college but the degree
options are limited at this point so if
there's that kind of ball in the court
too as well
yeah
okay
um
well I paid for all three of my
children's college education and it had
nothing to do that did not cause them to
not have an appreciation for the dollar
all three of them understand work ethic
all three of them understand the value
of a dollar and so your husband's full
of crap
on that subject
I have proof otherwise
um now I understand because I come from
the same
cut out the same cloth he's cut out of
he believes in hard work he believes in
earning your way and he believes it's
good for your kid to build those muscles
of self-reliance and uh Destiny and uh
control you know I I agree with all that
and I've got a friend who's a NFL
football player uh ex-nfl football
player who uh grew up blue collar dad
there was a dock worker and his dad said
they're not paying for nothing he went
to school on a scholarship playing
football and then went on into the NFL
and he refused to in the NFL making NFL
money to save anything for his kids
college so uh but uh the idea that the
only way your child learns the value of
a dollar is to make sure they have no
dollars is bullcrap
okay but they but but I do understand
his line of thinking so I don't disagree
with I understand how he got there he's
just wrong okay so you can teach a kid
the value of a dollar you can teach them
hard work even if they come from a
family of means even if they come where
they have a college fund
um and uh you can actually hold it over
their head make sure that they learn
these things you know
um uh and the other thing I would just
say is the other place I I and I do
agree with him that the trades are
oftentimes a better option than a stupid
but degree that is nuanced and has
absolutely no application in the real
world I'm going to get a degree in
German polka history and left-handed
puppetry and then and moan because
Society owes me something while I'm a
barista that's just dumb okay and that
happens all the time out there and I
don't I agree with him that we're not
going to salute that stupidity either
but to say that all kids don't need a
four-year education is ludicrous it's
nonsense so let me let me tell you this
um my grandmother my grandma smoked when
she was younger
she when she passed away she did not
pass away from lung cancer
that doesn't mean that lung cancer
doesn't give you or smoking doesn't give
you cancer I think we've proven
equivocally that that smoking increases
cancer rates exponentially
just because your husband got a
four-year degree and has found more
success in a trade
doesn't mean that all people who get
four years degrees are dumber than
people who get go to trades that's just
not how it works I nor does it mean the
opposite it would mean the opposite that
if you're if you get a go to a trade and
don't go get a four-year degree you're
dumb right because there's some people
need to do that too we need people on
the trades we need people but but to not
have a money allocated to cause the
future success of your child whether
it's a certification as a diesel
mechanic or and pay for that or whether
it's a four-year degree in business and
pay for that uh you're giving your kids
options when you do that when you have
no money set aside you took away a lot
of the options that's right and I will
I've got several friends who had
assistance with with financial
assistance uh my family was in a
position to do that and I will tell you
we are the same age and we all equally
work really hard
and the their ability to do some things
early on when it came to investing when
it came to home buying that I wasn't
able to do has accelerated their wealth
building because they had options and so
I'm like Dave I my kids will know how to
work hard they'll know how to how to
grind and hustle and what a dollar means
and Lord willin if I'm able to help them
pay for their college education or their
trades I'm gonna I'm gonna make every
effort possible to make that happen yeah
and so here's the thing 100 of the
humans out there unless they have a a a
a mental disability
need some kind of education post High
School
to be financially successful it's not a
hundred percent necessary but it's 98
necessary you really don't take a single
thing After High School you are behind
the curve and so you need to go get
certifications in Microsoft and go into
technology at the local community
college or Tech College that's fine
that's going into a trade you go be a
diesel mechanic that's fine be a welder
that's fine get your real estate license
get your real estate license that's fine
but continuing education throughout your
life
is the path of successful people we have
people that come in here they're 40
years old and applying for a leadership
role in there and I ask them what book
they've read and they can't remember one
well that disqualify
you know you don't get to come in here
and be a leader you're not learning
anything new you always are learning and
so you always want to encourage learning
is a is a continual process we love
books we love reading we love learning
uh but we re and we respect your ability
to go into the military we respect your
ability to go into a trade we respect
and those are fine career paths and
we've and the higher education
communities look down their nose at them
for too long so I agree with lifting
those up micro is a good friend of mine
we're in agreement about that dirty jobs
guy you know and so uh he's got a whole
movement on the trades thing and but
he's not against College he's got a
degree you know and this is Mr dirty
jobs for God's sakes you know and so uh
you know all of that to say I understand
completely and agree with why your
husband is saying what he's saying but I
think he's taking the wrong track
absolutely yeah I think you I think you
put the money aside money for future
learning will never go to waste like
it's all it's always the best time to
build a culture in your house of hard
work and future learning that's right
you know you're always going to be
learning you're always going to be
reading you're always going to be
reading I was telling the story of our
team yesterday we've adopted a school
here at Ramsey that was my old
elementary school and we were able to go
in several years ago and rebuild the
library and uh in the name of in the
honor of my old principal in out of our
family Foundation now our company is
adopting this and coming around these 83
teachers and trying to help them because
these poor teachers man they're just
getting it's just ridiculous out there
anyway but um
well they're showing that video that
Library I'll start crying I had to walk
out Dave I walked out because I was
crying like it came over and it's just
like because that library is where I
learned to read I came out of the first
grade in the second grade not knowing
how to read
and my second grade teacher bless your
heart didn't know how to teach and then
she she worked one year in those
hillbilly kids drove her out of the
business and so but um then the soccer
in the third grade reading on a first
grade level and Miss Mary Jane hurt
taught me to read and by the time I go
out of the fourth grade level uh the
fourth grade I'm reading on sixth grade
level so that little library and I've
got I've had seven number one
best-selling books sold 25 million books
that I wrote okay that doesn't happen
unless you read
a lot yeah that goes with the territory
so learning is a good thing learning is
a good thing so you know I I love guys
like your husband though Sierra I I
almost could get on his side on this
except he's wrong he's wrong
thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the Ramsey show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where
that is dumb Cassius king and the paid
off Home Mortgage has taken the place of
the BMW as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth new work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney number one
best-selling author and Ramsay
personality is my co-host today we'll
take your calls about your life and your
money the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five if
you've never tuned in to the new Dr John
deloney show it is wildly popular on
podcast one of the fastest growing
properties on the Ramsey networks right
now you can call in there with questions
about mental health issues and
boundaries and relatives and kids and uh
marriage and boy there's some fun stuff
on there and some of it's just crazier
than a bean
there's some stuff on there I love
listening to this show but man there is
some wacky butt stuff coming in on the
phone lines do some stuff man people are
going through it
people have some stuff some people's
kids
I mean it's it's amazing some people
that's that's the name of the book some
people's kids some people's kids oh my
gosh yeah it's uh but I mean it's uh
there's a lot of pain but there's also a
lot of resolution a lot of hope uh
because you do walk through I mean
psychology and mental Wellness mental
health is such a um
taboo subject because if you label
yourself with one of the disorders or
someone labels you with one of the
disorders or you
um accept that as your identity we're so
worse yet or you uh just decide that's
crazy and you just start calling
something crazy
um and it's like uh
all of a sudden it falls off into a
whole different bucket of life it just
goes into a black box and but and
there's so many things though that
people can do that are really Common
Sense things in that world that you can
t that you teach and that you believe
and man I I get a lot of listening to it
thank you it's a good show I appreciate
that it's it's very similar to money
it's just become over complicated and
over professionalized and over discussed
and there are some ish times that there
are some very very complex issues most
of the time most of us need to head
towards Simplicity yeah Common Sense
here and
um like no you can't act like that
around me anymore that's yeah I'm not
gonna accept that yeah and I I don't do
that I'm gonna leave all right I'm gonna
choose to do something new people that
do you yeah I don't do that yeah
that's um you're gonna have to get a
little distance like about a county or
two between us here yes it's not gonna
work
yeah
it's it's interesting man you're gonna
rage I don't I don't do Raging you're
gonna bully I don't do bullying yeah
it's uh pretty interesting stuff so um I
appreciate that check out the Dr John
baloney show at ramseysolutions.com you
can get the phone number the phone
number you know what else is up your
head
nope nope 16-3291
uh come on Kelly help us out here she's
just looking at us daring us to not know
it
just go to the email okay John
deloney.com
and then you can uh and Kelly will uh
I've got your Triple Eight two five five
two two five I got your number memorized
Power number I got the Ramsey Show
number memorized okay all right good
good we got that now okay we've solved
all of these issues now you can call the
Dr John deloney show and solve the rest
of them call this show for numbers
questions not because we don't know any
of them Mahmoud Is With Us in Phoenix
hey Mahmoud what's up hey Dave how are
you great man how can we help
well so um I started uh investing in
let's say may 2020 so that's after
covid-19 storming the market and back
then I was living in a different country
and I used to have an appointment that I
used to live in without paying anything
and so my investment Grew From a hundred
thousand dollars to 180 000 in terms of
my original investment
um in the process in 2021 I ended up
moving to the United States and I got my
first lease end of last year and it's
and I came here with the intention let's
say to buy property so I had around
let's say 120 000 in cash to use for the
down payment
um during that period of time the house
and market and the rent and Market has
gone up extremely high
and particularly in Phoenix
yes exactly and at this time the
same time they're doing well
I'm finding my
let's say a point where I have to make a
decision whether let's say to pull all
the cash that I have in the stock market
to use
either as a down payment or to pay as
much cash as possible for a property as
as things stand
um we will rent them and so um I'm
finding myself at a point where like
either like my rent is going to go up by
a certain percentage point
which might you know
well here's the problem
um you're in a hot rental market and
you're in a hot housing market in
Phoenix no pun intended it's 110 degrees
there right now but
um
you know so it you you're damned if you
do damned if you don't in a sense right
uh so you're going to pay some money out
for housing period to to live in Phoenix
right now it is
um it's not a down Market by any stretch
of the imagination nor is it going to be
anytime soon
so um so one thing to do out here
probably is
to relocate in to a little bit of
affordable Market of this time in terms
of housing okay but I think saying like
the Renton market and the house of
Market here as you mentioned it's like
yeah it's just white hot I mean it's
just it's a wonderful market in terms of
the economy it's just booming and so but
the uh but is it is making housing
um rough so anyway wherever you're going
to live take your time
not two years but not two days don't get
house fever and get all hot and bothered
and pay too much for something
so go take your time analyze the market
that place the neighborhood you're
looking at work with a good real estate
agent that knows their stuff and don't
overpay don't overpay and so
um and don't pull your money out of the
market well I would about to buy the
house I would oh you would yeah it's not
it's not in oh it's not retirement money
it's not in a retirement account all
right Mamu don't listen to me it's not
in a retirement account right it's it's
not so I'm just I'm going to use all the
money I get my hands on to do this deal
then
the cat the cash and the stock and the
money you've got in the stock market and
I know the Market's down it's not a
great time to pull your money out but
it's to John's point but right now what
I'm trying to do is just get you a house
and then get to her and get it paid off
as fast as you can you have an ability
to make money you always have and you
probably will continue to make good
money and you'll be able to work your
way right through this so you're going
to take some losses probably on that
stock market account but that's not the
end of the world go buy your house and
get you a good deal but go slow don't
get crazy don't get caught up in the
hype because the hype is about over it's
kind of slowed down out there a little
bit in a lot of places no not Phoenix
Phoenix is booming but
you know you and I had a friend the
other day that bought a house and um
the guy had it overpriced because he
thought he'd you know that he's going to
get one of these California sucker fish
coming in here to buy stuff and that's
what we call you California people that
overpay for stuff and so
um but the uh got a good deal on it but
the guy no it wasn't he bought it from
market price we have another friend same
guy he bought it for appraisal but 60
000 under asking because the guy the guy
was fishing for sucker fish he wasn't he
was looking for a sucker and he was
overpriced and our guy just said no and
they've been on the market three whole
days so the seller panicked and gave it
away
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you three months free to
get started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hallow.com Ramsay today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
we are highlighting some discussions on
insurance today we're big on talking
about the importance of insurance Matt
is with us in Greenville South Carolina
Matt talk about how insurance has
impacted your life
hey how you guys doing over there today
great man how are you
uh doing absolutely awesome so um it was
around July of 2020 when I was in a car
accident and uh thankfully because of
the coverage that we got that we got uh
through um you know through the coverage
of the elt I was able to
um I was able to have not only money
from uh from uh from the company but
also from our emergency fund to be able
to replace that car within a couple of
months but the funny part is it's a
weird time to be buying a car wasn't it
yeah but um
[Music]
yeah tell me about it but the funny
thing was like not even six months later
my wife was in a car accident and so we
had to go through the whole process
again
no way no I am not kidding you and it
was and it was one of those just after
we had recovered from that and now we
got to go back to the emergency fund
again to hit uh to take care of that
along with what we got from the
insurance company but thankfully we were
able to replace that and by the summer
of 21 we were actually able to finish
building our emergency fund and now
we're saving for a house very good so
you have a heightened awareness about
all this insurance stuff for sure then
don't you uh yes sir so what do you tell
somebody when they act like they don't
need to worry about insurance because
you're like a walking claim
yeah uh it's not a matter of if it
happens to you it's when it happens to
you so I know it'll sound like a big
expense and then one of those things
that's just kind of but when it happens
to you you'll be glad that you have it
amen amen so you went through the
confidence in your coverage series with
George camel right
yes I did excellent you did excellent on
that by the way he did I thought it was
really good it was funny and fun and
informative and it was short it didn't
it didn't choke it didn't choke you down
too much so what was the biggest thing
you got out of that
uh just the urgency to be to get this
stuff done now it's not um and uh one
thing I tell people don't think about it
as part of the baby steps just take care
of it as soon as you can that's exactly
right I agree with that completely well
Matt thank you for sharing all that
that's actually great great input very
very good stuff so if you want to see
this uh five video series confidence in
your coverage you go to
ramseysolutions.com confidence and it is
a free five video guide on insurance it
is short it is fun it is funny and it is
informative so it's not too painful
George makes a a pretty yucky uh subject
uh entertaining as often George does so
uh check it all out ramsesolutions.com
confidence oh by the way it's completely
free Brian's in Omaha Nebraska hey Brian
welcome to the Ramsey show what's up
hey Dave how's it going better than we
deserve how can we help
uh yeah
um so my question is well I guess
there's there should be a little bit of
backstory
um me my girlfriend and my six month old
we moved out of the apartment that we
were staying at
um
they were raising the rent on us and
then uh we just our her parents decided
to let us stay at their house until we
were able to save enough money to either
buy a house or rent another another
house or apartment and um basically I
feel kind of I feel kind of horrible for
doing that I don't feel like
I I don't feel like as good as I should
because I know saving up is what we need
to do and I know I have some debt to pay
off so I want to use the opportunity to
to actually save and pay off as much
debt as possible before
um the six months to a year is up that
they had allowed us to stay
um but I mean is it I guess one of my
questions is is that is that the right
thing that I did or should I have just
kind of manned up and try to pay the
extra money that they were charging or
and then also
um I mean what's the next step here
because I know paying the debt off is a
big one but it just doesn't feel like I
can do it in the amount of time that I'm
being given so let me jump in number one
paying an accelerated rent rake has
nothing to do with manhood
that
uncouple those number two why do you
feel awful you said you feel awful
um I've always been that type of person
to never accept
help so okay
you feel like you feel like a charity
case you feel like you're failing your
wife and your kid
yeah okay
how old are you
uh 26 what do you do for a living
I'm a mechanic for a dealership cool
what do you make
um I haven't completed a full year
um so I know I get paid about 2 800 a
month I think over a year it'd be 40 45
000 yeah sounds right and uh if you've
completed your year does your income go
up
I'm not entirely sure about that I know
after like six months they did it did
come up pretty good
um but uh after a year I believe it
should I just don't know how much are
you ASI
uh ASE no um I have a couple ases done
but not completely certified
um I guess that counts and then the
dealership that I work for they have
their own training that they want you to
apply for work outside
uh she doesn't
um we haven't been able to afford like
daycare so she's uh she stays at home
well if she made a hundred thousand
dollars a year you could afford it what
did she do
well she doesn't work
does she have a degree
no she's in school right now um like I
said I'm 26 and but she's 20 and she's
going for uh edu our sociology
so Brian I
I'll just take a page out of my own
story
um I
took on the burden of student loan debt
between me and my wife I had about six
figures we did together
um and ultimately we sold our house and
I moved us at my assistance
um and she went along with it into a
residence hall a dorm
with a two-year-old and I felt like a
loser
and I felt like a failure
and I looked at the math
and I came to terms with the fact that
the single most quote-unquote manly
thing I could do
would be to have a really hard year
an uncomfortable 18 months
and in that 18 months we didn't spend
anything and we paid off six figures in
a very short amount of time we took I
took extra jobs I worked like crazy
and in retrospect I can't think of a
better thing I did to stop the madness
stop the sunk cost stop dumping money
into my pride and ego and to stop and
say I need help
and the help came through this this area
right and then we got after got to work
and then put a period at the end of that
sentence and moved on
asking should you have moved is if
you've already moved so asking yourself
that question is a waste of energy ask
yourself should you move again maybe
that may be another question to ask
but going back and saying and debating
that decision you've already made it man
let that roll off don't carry that
sucker around with you
how much uh debt do you have
um I have about
6 000 in credit cards
um 500 in school loans
um 17 in
in car payments and then
um who has the 17 000 car you're your
wife
I do um it's the only reliable car we
have but uh right now I know that
um it's got some hail damage that is
getting repaired as soon as that gets
repaired I know I'm gonna try and get
rid of it as soon as possible yeah good
I'll get you a hoopty and get yourself
out of debt it's a good time to be
selling a used car
okay
um here's the thing
um I don't know how mature emotionally
your 20 year old wife is but she needs
to make some income
even if it's working from home even if
it's selling stuff on eBay she needs to
get off her butt and uh you need to get
off your butt and figure out what your
income is and how you can go make more
you don't even know what you make for
sure and you don't know what your uh
promotion process is you need to go get
some money both of you and get this mess
cleaned up and get your autonomy back
and get your sustainability back and
when you get autonomous again on your
own on your own two feet and both of you
have a plan you're going to be making
some money and you're going to be
winning again but right now you're just
wandering living in your mama's basement
her mama's basement
thank you
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Jack
and Brittany are with us hey guys how
are you hi there good how are you doing
better than we deserve welcome where do
you live uh we live in Houston or
correction Cypress Texas just uh just
north of Houston Texas very cool welcome
to Nashville all the way up here to do a
debt free scream how much did you pay
off we paid off 338
405 dollars excellent how long did this
take
um about seven years and 10 months good
for you guys I love it and your range of
income during that time uh we started
about 107 000
um and with a second job we are now
about a 200 maybe a little over
good for you what do you guys do for a
living I work in the fire department As
A Firefighter and my wife's a elementary
school teacher oh cool what grade do you
teach third grade oh fun yeah good for
you thanks for being there thank you we
need people like you out there right now
good stuff well done what kind of debt
was this 338
000 over seven years is that the house
it is yeah
it is it was a couple of small credit
cards uh some things we bought for that
house
um vehicle loans and then of course uh
last and not least the mortgage I love
it look at it weird people
you too I'm 36 and she turns 21 Thursday
thank you I'll be 35 on Thursday ah
happy birthday thank you way to go
what's the house worth of about 450 000
maybe you know maybe more 38 bids later
I don't know but and you own it and
you're not even 40. I love it you guys
are amazing congratulations thank you so
seven years ago you're in your 20s and
you decide you're going to be weirdos
and pay off your house before you're 40.
tell me about this story how did you get
connected to Ramsey how did you start
this process
um we were introduced to financial peace
through my sister and brother-in-law
um started watching the videos and just
made the decision that we were ready to
change our lives yeah yeah I'm a love
math I love numbers so when we started
looking at a bigger house as we grew our
family
um
that started to scare me a bit so I
didn't really know if we could afford it
and that kind of thing with with growing
the family and and um Child Care
groceries and and going out to eat and
all that stuff so
um I mean that's kind of how we we got
connected we haven't ever really been
bad with money more just disorganized if
you can say that so okay but going into
financial piece you just said game on
uh yeah we did
um yeah we we laid out the the plan
um as you said it and um
and just went from there yeah you know
the weird thing is is that aren't data
on people going through financial pieces
the average paying off their home in
about seven years the average
millionaire pays off their home in uh 11
years and the average millionaire
listening to our stuff is 10.2 years so
that that's actual hard data the other
stuff's anecdotal but
um the earlier one but you guys fit the
mold exactly so well done you're well on
your way to being Millionaires and also
so how much is in your retirement
accounts uh well with the recent
downturn of the market uh that put us
just under
um so so you're millionaires yes yes you
were yeah okay and as soon as the market
turns back up a little you will be again
yeah we're just just under the mark now
way to go guys
40 babies have millionaires wow
feature I could never make it you know
by the way the number three uh
occupation of people who become
millionaires as teacher
and so uh y'all are the fun ruiners
you're you're the excuse takers yeah
anybody who's out there whining I teach
third grade I'm a millionaire but I'm
35. exactly
how are you able to be a fireman without
like a huge F-350 all jacked up in
a hundred thousand dollar truck on
payments were you able to make it man
yes uh it was it was tough uh they gave
it to you huh as we we got nor uh
further towards the end of our journey
you know our
income is a lot we're throwing a lot at
the house and um you know new trucks
right right there driving into the
station
it hurts uh so it's rough uh and they
let you have it too huh oh yeah yeah
they did they did they're not
millionaires they're not paid for house
that's true dad gum truck all right I
love it that's just awesome man Wow way
to go how's it feel it feels great yeah
it feels great you got to be a captain
of your own destiny man I mean you're
incredible yeah it does this this month
uh well now probably
maybe a month or two ago it's probably
it's finally set in we paid the house
off January 20 uh 24th I believe
um and uh
we really haven't had you know January I
Rec we we do a lot of dirt bike riding
as a hobby so our headquarters had a
wreck hurt my knee I had to repair the
bike and things like that and then
um AC went out in the house of course
two months after we paid it all so just
things like that happened so it wasn't
until about April or May when we really
started we don't have any plans for this
extra money now you know that kind of
thing so hey imagine 10 years ago versus
when your air conditioner went out this
time it was just annoying it was it was
annoying yes it wasn't what are we going
to do you're not looking at two little
boys saying what are we gonna do right
yeah that that's made the process so
easy and that's with anything I mean
with gas going up to five dollars a
gallon just about I mean it's just an
inconvenience Force really it doesn't
stop us from doing
uh what we enjoy you know and uh and um
and you know we're still investing and
saving and and just cruising right along
giving you know that's one thing that
we've really
um that we really noticed is is just it
is huge yeah well we can give back yeah
it's fantastic guys
very cool good for you guys thank you
well done well done we're proud of you
all right you brought the kiddos with
you what are their names and ages bring
them up we have Trevor who's 11 and Owen
that's eight all right very good good
job good job all right what was the
hardest part of this for you guys
I mean you know we didn't have very many
arguments over it you know we both were
pretty you know together on doing it
um but that's I mean no real hard part
except for just sticking with it you
know and and waiting for that light at
the end of the tunnel yeah like I said
earlier I was a numbers guy so I I
wanted to throw just about every penny
we had at dead and then of course at the
house so you know we had a few
disagreements about what we put in the
envelopes each week or each month we do
ours every every week
um
but uh we had a few disagreements then
um and uh she she helped work me loosen
up a little bit and release some of that
grocery money and and fun money and
things like that so absolutely well you
should borrow your own baby steps four
through seven yeah both those boys do
have shoes on so that's good
way to go you guys all right uh what do
you tell people the biggest key to
getting out of debt is
um I think it's it's like the other debt
free scream said earlier the budget and
communication
um you know when we started we were
writing it down and and now you know
we've kind of gone electronically but
um but communicating and having those
discussions
um being content with uh with uh with
what you have
um
and and I think it just it all it all
comes back down to the to the budget and
and we you know we didn't stop spending
we just put it down on paper and
organized it and and still you know
still did our our snow trips
um you know once we got out of our
Consumer Debt and still did some Disney
trips and things like that but uh
intentional but we just saved for it you
know it took us a year to save for it
but we saved for it you know and so and
just making the money behave all the way
that's it ever go back in debt uh sir no
sir nope not even for an F-150
close uh and I don't know how much time
we got left but I got super close and
almost made a mistake a very small
mistake and taking another loan and uh
and my wife and Brittany she snapped me
back real quick
but I didn't say for a year for
Disneyland for you to get it yeah that's
right I love it way to go you guys all
right we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires a Financial Peace
University and Total Money Makeover for
you count it down 338
000 house and everything baby steps
millionaire
years making 107 to 200 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
Ah that's how it's done
this is the Ramsay show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
backed by their 100 percent satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
50 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life
and about your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five uh Max is with us in Salt Lake City
hi Max welcome to the Ramsay show
afternoon gentlemen I appreciate you
accepting my call sure what's up
yes sir so I'm a 50 year old married
male um we've been married for about
seven years I believe we could retire
um but I'm not sure if we should
okay
what's the goal what do you want to do I
I guess I guess that's the concern um
we've been we've been very fortunate
we've played by the rules
um I've had a spreadsheet budget that
each tab goes back to all the way to
1999. wow
um and so I have if you it's kind of
like a reading the rings on a tree if
you go to a certain time you can kind of
see what happened in my life in that
specific mirror
um but we have four rental homes uh we
have one one pension already secured and
we received that each month my wife
works and I also have another career now
we should get a second uh pension in
five years when I'm 55 through the
military
um and so I guess and what is your net
worth
honestly I I don't know uh we need to
account for our full rental homes they
are paid off we live in the fifth wheel
we've lived in the fifth wheel for about
five years now so that we can make uh
have cash flow through the rentals
um I would estimate probably 600 650 000
uh net net worth
um and I guess the biggest concern then
you hit it on the nail on the head when
you said what's the goal um each what I
have found that for a very long time now
I've always had woken up and had a goal
had something I wanted to achieve had
something I wanted to you know a medal I
wanted to put on my chest or something I
wanted to throw my wall
um I never thought that uh 50 years old
I would kind of be lost because I don't
know if we should go for a fifth home I
don't know if we should just call it
good we're making now uh 14 14.2 a month
left
um our total expenditures each month
outflow are about 2.3
um and I I kind of had this wild dream
of I'm a I've Been A Private Pilot since
I was 18 to 32 years and I was talking
to my wife that maybe maybe someday I
can take about 35
000 and go after a instructor reading
and maybe I can do that part-time until
basically the FAA says I I'm too old to
do it but then I don't think I'm going
to make the return on the investment if
I did that I guess I'm just looking for
some
something to wake up in the morning for
[Music]
um
but the money is easy that's the numbers
are easy
um now that we're here I don't know yeah
I do want you to change gears though
from doing your duty uh because you're a
man of Honor who's always done his duty
to uh finding something that you make
money doing while actually enjoying it
okay
and I don't care if you make a lot of
money it wouldn't make me mad
the challenge about the question
the challenge about the question you're
asking Max is you've Roi Joy
you've put a spreadsheet to what matters
and you you spreadsheeted out
relationships you've spreadsheeted out
excitement you've spreadsheeted out
happiness you've spreadsheet out joy
and it's very hard to capture those
things with it with it with a 10 key
and the the challenges you're asking a
question what what can I go do what can
I go seek that's going to fill that Gap
inside of me and that's going to come
from the inside out not the outside in
so the question Dave's asking you is a
profound one what do you want to do man
yeah and so here I'll give you a hint
okay
um I'm gonna send you uh Ken Coleman's a
career assessment and his new book from
paycheck to purpose because what's
missing here is purpose yep
um and uh I'll give you a place to look
find something where you're serving
other people and making their life
better that makes you smile
and then I want you to do that with
great scale and go make a million
dollars doing that
because you're only 50. you've still got
20 or 25 good hard years of work that
you can bring value to other people's
lives and um by the way if you do that
in a proper way inside your skill set
they will give you as my friend Rabbi
Daniel lappen says certificates of
appreciation with presidents faces on
them
when you serve others and make their
life better they are grateful just like
when you have a great experience in a
high-end white tablecloth restaurant you
are more than happy to say thank you to
the person who served you by leaving an
outrageous tip
and that's the way the economy should
work is when we serve each other
there's a transfer of wealth that
results and I want you to get that
um because you've just been grinding
on my notes Here Dave as he's just
talking you can see the word I wrote I
wrote the word service oh I just wrote
that word down as he was speaking the
only way out of this trap is to go be
about making somebody else's life better
and it doesn't have to be a non-profit
nope
um you know we can argue that Steve Jobs
like him or not like apple or not maybe
lots of people's lives better with these
magic wands we carry around in our hands
called phones
that we can do anything with now and uh
became bazillionaires because they made
a bunch of Life people's life better and
we can go on from there or something as
silly as you were with me at a park a
few uh maybe a month or two ago
and your wife and Henry Cloud had to
peer pressure me into getting on a
roller coaster because I'm scared
terrified of heights that's my that's my
thing
and the other day you and I jumped out
of an airplane together
um with a guy with parachutes with
parachutes Yes we made it but but
otherwise we would have left our Mark
but somebody left it all on the field
served us laughter and joy and
overcoming fears and that dude was
incredible and he kept us safe and he
walked us through it that's a service as
far as I mean it was it was a thing they
were incredible incredible the team you
know made skydiving not terrifying yes
yes which is less than I can say about
you pulling us on a tube behind your
boat right
but here's the deal I was trying to
serve you sir you you served you up to
the water I'm about 18 Lake water right
now yeah um but the service can look
like a lot of different things but it's
going out and saying where can I bring
people Joy where can I meet a need in
the environment in the world that's not
being met and go do that thing for other
people
all right
absolutely yeah that that's going to
help in this situation so mathematically
you can do a lot of stuff
you've got some pensions and you've got
some margin and you've got some net
worth and you've got time
um I do think you need to change gears
oh I'll tell you the book you ought to
read I got it it's called half time by
Bob Buford and
um Bob the thesis of the book for those
of you that haven't read half time it's
an old book but it's a great book is
that men particularly males when they
reach halftime in the game
uh they go from acquisition
to significance and if you don't move
from acquisition in the first half of
your life to significance in the second
half of your life if you don't make that
move uh you're susceptible to midlife
crisis blondes and convertibles wow and
so you're going to find significance
doing something you're going to find
excitement doing something in the second
half first half is just grinding and
acquisition is fine and by the way the
first half is not a chronological thing
it's an emotional thing I did my half
time at 28 when I went broke and so I
reached the point after going broke I
don't give a crap when anybody thinks
I'm gonna do what I'm supposed to do I
went to significance which is this thing
has been I've done for 30 years now plus
30 plus years
so um been on the air for 30 years but
uh uh the uh but that's that that whole
movement there's a movement there that's
tied to the midlife crisis idea and all
that kind of stuff but you know you're
just having a chronologically a little
bit later half time it doesn't mean
you're emotionally stunted that's not
what I'm saying but this guy you know
that we're talking to here Max but I I
think you know hey
you know what's the next adventure yeah
look for an adventure of service a man
without a purpose is an untethered scary
dangerous person go find a purpose man
yeah yeah go sir hang on I'll have
Austin pick up we're going to send you a
copy of that
um can call alikins materials and
assessment and the book as well from
paycheck to purpose this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off Home Mortgage has taken the place of
the BMW
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
really love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author mental health expert is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
and your life it's a free call a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Lynn is with us in Rochester New York hi
Lynn how are you
I'm great Dave how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
okay well um when they said I was great
honestly we have a crisis and we need
your help solving
um my husband was offered a dab in North
Carolina
and granted it's only 15 or excuse me 15
cents more an hour
but what we would save in taxes and
everything else would be astronomical
um we put our home on the market the
real estate agent said that we will get
we should get 169.9 for it hopefully
there will be a bidding more but he said
the Market's kind of soft so it might
not happen we found out that we have a
mean on the home from past medical debt
of 21
000 and we owe 120 000 on the home
so if our home goes from 169.9
after we pay the lien and pay the home
off we're like we're gonna net
seven to ten thousand
and my question to you is should we take
it off the market
and just
Hammer off the debt
and then go forth with North Carolina
what is the uh what is the history on
this twenty one thousand dollar medical
debt
I was in a car accident 10 years ago and
we fought back and forth with the
insurance
um
to take care of it they never did
and then my husband I got ill with lupus
and wasn't able to work and my husband's
Sole Provider so things got pushed off
to the side and that was wonderful so
the moral of the story is uh that um
ignoring things doesn't make them go
away
exactly
sure the 21 000 medical debt that they
finally sued you on and took a lien
against your house on but have never
gonna shoot your wages and that that
lawsuit was how long ago
yeah yeah how long ago
um how long ago
um oh goodness probably five years ago
they are garnishing his wages now
I bet they are
okay
when were you all planning on dealing
with this
oh
to be honest
because we're paying it we just assumed
that naively I guess that's even a word
that what is your what is your household
income
my husband makes about 70 000 with
overtime and the move to North Carolina
was prompted by what what makes you want
to go down there
we felt years ago God's calling us to
North Carolina at just that we love the
area we love the people
and
just life in general we feel would be
better there because here in New York
the taxes are astronomical I need more
pain okay here's the thing if you sell
your house you get a fresh start and you
get rid of this mess that you haven't
dealt with and you get to move on with
your life that's a beautiful thing okay
the only downside of that process is you
probably could negotiate this twenty one
thousand dollar debt
uh you know you probably offer them five
or ten dollars they probably take it as
settlement in full
you have the ability to borrow any money
no we don't
could you go to your credit union and
get five or ten thousand dollars
we might be able to uh
my husband's credit isn't the greatest
right now no kidding because of the the
debt right I know big surprise
okay so I I would ask your credit union
if there's any chance that they would
loan you five or ten thousand dollars
don't take the money if they approve the
loan though get that in writing and then
go to the lawyers uh that have the that
have done the lawsuit on the medical
debt and see if you can settle this for
a quarter or 50 cents on the dollar if
you can do that that'll get the lien
removed for less than twenty one
thousand and then that would put a
little more money in your pocket as you
sell the house
if you want to go that route you can if
you don't want to go that route just
sell your house at least you'll be rid
of the garnishment and you will have
gotten this from over the top of your
head but please for God's sakes learn
the lesson from it
the lesson is this stuff doesn't go away
unless you make it go away
it just gets worse it's like a splinter
under the skin
that's very true yeah ignoring it these
things have a high rate of Resurrection
they come back
over and over and over and over again
and so you have to push that stuff
through and I'm fussing at both you and
your husband for your own good because I
want you to prosper and you're not going
to prosper with that habit in blaze
so yes I'm selling your house uh yes I'm
going to try to settle that debt for
less than the face of it is because it
is a 10 year old medical dad and they
probably will take less on it
um but
maybe they won't now that they got a
garnishment and also but when you get to
North Carolina it may mean you have to
rent for a year or two yeah you don't
need money yeah you can't come in here
and just buy your dream house in North
Carolina yeah right and uh but 15 cents
an hour raise with no income tax and no
garnishment
that's a bigger bigger than 15 cent an
hour raise and I feel like you've won so
um yeah you're going to come out ahead
that way so and you know you get a fresh
start and you kind of get you know
different different setting and
everything so I'm with you on the move
overall and that's what I would try to
do Megan is with us in Atlanta Hi Megan
how are you
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call how are you better than we deserve
what's up all right
um well I am just looking for some
advice so
um last October I got a um bill in the
mail that I owed Verizon Wireless four
thousand dollars and it ended up being a
fraudulent bill I have never had or I
had an account many many many years ago
with them
um I worked with I have um in place
identity for our protection I worked
with my team there in getting that all
resolved
um I thought we were all good with
everything
um I ended up buying a condo not too
long ago and um so have been paying
pretty close attention to my credit
report and I just got a message last
week that I owed
um 4 600 to a collections agency yeah
and it's yeah you're gonna have to go
back here I didn't Theft Protection
again that's what it's for and they will
have to work it through
that's the only way you can do it
there's not even there's not any way
around it that's the downside of this
the good news is if you have good
Identity Theft Protection like Xander
Insurance then they will do the work for
you and fight these things off and push
them aside you have bad they make you do
have them work
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us America we are so
glad you're with us we appreciate you
I'm Dave Ramsey your host Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services neighborhood he's got 19
service Brands Nationwide and a network
of local service pros Molly Maid Mr
Rooter plumbing and Loan Pride to name
just a few visit neighborly.com to find
available service providers near you all
right today's question comes from Amanda
in Oregon Amanda writes my husband and I
got married last May at the time I did
not realize he had over 25 thousand
dollars in credit card debt plus a
personal loan I also didn't directly ask
him if he had a bunch of credit card
debt but we did have a conversation
where it made where he made it seem that
we were on the same page
I have a little debt the five thousand
dollar credit card and eight thousand
dollar remaining on my car and I've been
working to get this debt paid off when I
found out about his
at this point do I keep snowballing my
debt or now reconfigure everything and
put my money towards his debt as well oh
Dave this marriage is in trouble already
in trouble already
um
my friend Amanda
number one you gotta deal with the trust
issue here
um sounds like you all had a
conversation and he heard what you had
to say about it and he was dishonest by
his silence
and second
yes now that you know it's here this
idea that you're going to pay off your
quote-unquote little debt and he needs
to pay off his big debt and you got to
take your money and put it on his debt
y'all are married this is y'all's money
paying off y'all's debt
this is something y'all do together and
that tells me that y'all are married and
y'all are probably doing a decent job so
far being roommates that y'all are not
all in together on this deal at all
yeah it's very very important that you
uh combine your incomes and combine your
debts
and change your change your uh pronouns
it's you're now French we we
us our not his mine
and
um that's your best route out and that's
going to involve a commitment uh from
him
to extreme honesty from this point
forward and by you to clearly ask
questions
and the two of you need to be on a
written detailed budget together
where every dollar of your household
income the whole income come into the
house is going to be spent on the every
dollar app
and both of you see where every dollar
is going before the month begins
and both of you are in agreement and
both of you stick to that no secrets no
side jobs no side issues they're side
jobs the money goes right in the top of
the budget just like everything else but
there's no little deal where you've got
this secret Target Fund or he has a
secret gun fund or whatever it is right
I might have had a secret gun fund one
time but I didn't have that in Oregon
they'd have to have a high high five
that's right yeah that's there's that
okay but but so here's and we're going
to be doing the marriage and or the
money and marriage just for them in
Nashville it's October 19th and 21st
um and guys if you guys want to come to
that there's a few tickets left Rachel
and John are going to be doing a three
day long event with some other outside
speakers coming in a very interesting
lineup and a lot of stuff covered on the
money issue and on the marriage issues
uh and it's a whole Nashville weekend
it's going to be a blast yeah it's gonna
be everything from lessons on uh money
and how to deal with conflict and sex
and intimacy the whole thing we're not
leaving any stone unturned and um we've
done some some preliminary calls with
folks who've already bought their
tickets and we're part of the Platinum
purchase that sold out but
um people aren't interested in having as
much of a Kumbaya experience as they
want to get in and do some hard work and
we also have a
we have a lot of cool fun Nashville
things planned for the weekend so it's
gonna be a blast yeah there's some good
Nashville participation it's a blast
ramseysolutions.com event for the money
and marriage event and in your case
um Amanda you guys are going to have to
work really hard to get on the same page
and that's trust that's TR and that
trust is built by cooperation and
spending together and lots and lots and
lots of clear no deception communication
and no uh no deceiving by silence either
that's I think that's the most the worst
kind I mean I almost rather you'll just
lie to my face with your mouth
then just sneaker let me feel like in my
heart we're on the same page yeah then
just sneaky just sneaky like you know
passion aggressive so in this kind of
situation I think the smartest thing to
do would be both of y'all go pull your
credit report let's put them on the
table and let's go let's go top to
bottom and I think make Amanda feel
better about what's actually out there
because now she's got that little bit of
doubt that would make him if he's just
kind of a clueless I don't know then
everybody can be on the same page yeah
you can't loaf your way through this
yeah you're gonna have to deal with it
every dime of it yeah that's that that's
the only shot you got because if you
guys continue to half butt do this
relationship and half butt do this money
and either one of them is going to work
and that's what you've been doing all
right Elizabeth is with us in Cincinnati
hi Elizabeth how are you
I'm fine how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
well
well first off I've loved the book
and I loved meeting your day chill a
couple of years ago well thank you
and our oldest son is the one who
introduced us to Dave Ramsey
and after we seen Rachel we went home
and we got busy okay and
we are me and my husband both will be
turning 60 next month
and we have seven children who are now
all out the door yay and yeah
and we have really worked really hard
and
we were very late in starting 401k
once we started doing all of our savings
we had a couple of catastrophes in our
house
which we had to Do complete remodels
guts bathroom and kitchen because of
black mold so it wasn't beautification
this was health issues
so goodbye savings
and
at this point we only have
a house payment
one car payment
with sixteen hundred dollars left on it
and after covid
my husband took a 10 cut and pay lost
his bonuses and with the remodels that
we had to do
we I budget everything I use
spreadsheets I we use cash allowances
but I'm to the point now
I'm my husband has turned over the
finances to me so I don't want to
disappoint him I want to keep him on the
same track
so my question is
we are late getting our 401K but we have
a hundred thousand
we owe 73 000 on our health
her house will not be paid for until
we're 72.
and we have a eight thousand dollar
credit card bill because it's a medical
because our savings was gone
do you have any savings that's not in
the 401K
we have six thousand okay
okay which book did you read
The Total Money Makeover and I've had to
start over yeah
you needed both of you get the book out
because number one he turned the money
over to me no
well I know no no no no no don't don't
well me no just know no the two of you
need to sit down and make these
decisions together you don't get to
carry this by yourself superhero you
don't get that privilege the two of you
need to make these decisions and carry
this weight he doesn't get to bow out
like a coward and say oh whatever I'll
just he didn't get to do that either no
so what does he make
he makes 113. what do you make
Mr Nice our son passed away I kind of
are you still
yes I am are they paying you
none one of them does good okay so you
get you need to get the book back out
and start working back through the dead
snowball leave your 401k alone get the
stupid credit card paid off the stupid
car paid off and then let's build an
emergency fund and then let's put 15 of
our income away and then let's start
working on paying off the house and both
of you need to do everything you can to
maximize your income and I want your
debt free house and everything in five
years you can do that
[Music]
thank you
Dr chandeloni Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
all month long we're giving away cash
you can win one of our 500 weekly prizes
or the grand prize of three thousand
dollars enter daily at
ramseysolutions.com giveaway while
you're there you can pre-order Dr John
deloney's brand new book building a
non-anxious life you'll learn the six
daily choices to break free from a life
spinning out of control plus when you
pre-order today for just twenty dollars
you get 75 dollars worth of free bonus
items helps John helps you everybody
gets a deal I think everybody's winning
building a non-anxious life
ramseysolutions.com
store Ryan is in Birmingham hey Ryan
welcome to the Ramsey Show
what's going on hey what's up
hey man so I just had a couple of
questions for you uh I recently have a
quit gambling and uh I'm kind of in the
hole right now and I just need some
advice
what what kind of gambling were you
doing
uh specifically uh double deck Blackjack
um and a fair amount of toker Texas hold
'em online
uh no sir
um no sir how much have you lost
uh I'd say about a year ago I had like a
four day stretch where I won and lost
about six figures
okay
so you recently quit gambling tell me
about that what's that mean
uh I'd say I haven't played cards in
about two months
um and my debt to income is great I just
keep putting myself in the same uh the
same hole yeah
you've had a gambling problem and you
just decided I quit and that's it that
that's all you've done so would you
backfill that hole with
um man I I am behind on Grant uh three
Corvette three car payments uh I owe
probably about twenty five hundred
dollars to friends of mine and uh right
now I'm just kind of living check to
check
but you quit gambling 60 days ago so
what six months ago six months ago what
have you done in the meantime that has
continued to make your your life
problems so challenging
well so I took a loan from a friend for
about 10 grand and then I was paying him
back payments after I'd lost that uh
large sump of money and uh so I've been
kind of paying him back when I can
um and then my student loans just said
I've got about eighty four thousand
dollars worth of student loan debt what
do you mean that's about uh probably
around I'd say I'm in sales so I'd say
this year I'm on track to make about
150. and you're single
yes sir okay how old are you
I'm 22.
what have you
been going to Gamblers Anonymous or are
you seeing a therapist or anything
uh I just I had my first uh meeting with
a counselor a Christian counselor of
Wednesday could I have another meeting
next week oh okay good I appreciate it
that's what that's what I was worried
about because okay good yeah my dad he's
a pastor and uh man he acts like he
doesn't have two dimes to rub together
but I mean he'll he'll definitely retire
a millionaire for sure uh and it's it's
hard to talk about my finances with him
uh because he'd be so so angry with me
uh you know and so you know I kind of
just accepted the fact that I needed
help and good
um I'm upset with myself so time to make
some changes for sure an important part
to get an important part of getting well
is finding
um this word gets thrown around
culturally so
um I don't mean in the uh
never tells me the truth kind of way um
it doesn't hold me accountable kind of
way but part of getting well is finding
a safe person or safe people that you
can actually say hey I'm not all right
and I've dug myself a mask and um
sometimes our dads aren't that sometimes
our moms aren't that sometimes our
spouses aren't that it doesn't it
doesn't relieve us of the fact that we
gotta go find people and I'm proud of
you for doing that man yeah that's very
important part of this conversation Ryan
now now that you've done that what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
move from chaos
which this out of control feeling that
an addiction gives you and the chaos
that results in your finances and the
chaos that results in your career and
the chaos that results in your
relationships you're trying to move
wisely from chaos to order
you're trying to bring order to these
different areas of your life that's at
least what you should be doing but and
it sounds like that's what you're asking
to do and I'm proud of you for that as
well so the thing we're going to do with
your money is we're going to put you on
a very strict budget where you don't get
to do anything except pay off debt and I
want you to list your debts smallest to
largest and start paying them in that
order and I don't want you going out to
eat I don't want you in a bar and I
don't want you doing anything except
working
and uh getting these debts cleaned up
did you say your three car payments
behind or you have three cars
three car payments behind uh I I my next
check hits tomorrow uh can you bring it
current with that check
um so my rent I I spent about 1500 a
month and bills uh and you know now that
I'm behind how much are the car payments
oh it's 259. okay so you need 750 what's
your check gonna be
uh it's gonna be about after it's
actually about 987 it's my drawing so
I'm on a 2 000 draw and then I get my
commission at the end of the month
um
okay you have any money in your account
now thank you very much I have about a
hundred bucks to my name right now okay
I want you to take care and you haven't
paid the rent yet
no sir how much is your rent
uh it's about a thousand bucks okay I
want you to call your landlord and tell
him that you're going to pay him two
rent payments at the end of the month
that you can't pay him right now because
you got to keep your car from being
repoed okay I'm sorry and you call him
before when you get off the phone and
tell him that and he's not going to do
anything he's not gonna like it but
you're gonna pay him two payments at the
first of the month because you got
enough coming in to do that because
you're making good money you're just not
made but it all comes in at the end of
the month right
yes sir okay and you only can do two
things right now with this with this
check eat
and get the car caught up because at 90
days they're gonna pick the car up man
yep you're at the repo point they are
not going to screw around you're gonna
look up there's gonna be no car in the
driveway and a wrecker running down your
street that's right where you are yeah
who do you owe this money to uh
you talking about the gambling debt no
the uh the car payment
oh uh just keeps the uh Federal Credit
Union okay
uh so that's a local credit union in
your area
oh yes sir uh I think they're based out
of Biloxi call them and see if you can
give them two payments out of this check
tomorrow and give you a little bit of
money to cut is your is your electric
bill behind too
um wait what was that is your
electricity and water behind as well
um so I have a roommate and he's taking
care of that and I was kind of fill them
in where I'm at and uh he's taking care
of some of the utilities I might have to
pay him back uh okay but uh all right
because here's the here's the rule
you're looking for
okay food
shelter
clothing which you probably don't need
any of transportation and utilities
everyone else Waits until those are
current
food you eat not out to eat groceries
baloney hot dogs beans and rice
okay
food
utilities shelter which is rent and
transportation so you get this car
straightened up you get your landlord
straightened up you get your roommate
straightened up on the utilities before
we talk about paying anybody
I don't care who they are you got to
take care of your four walls of survival
before you move on to the next thing
does that make sense to you
it does absolutely it is the fastest way
for you to get to these other people now
once your car is current what will you
owe on it
uh my balance is about 12. and what do
you owe you have ten thousand dollars on
a gambling debt and what else
um I own I owe 900 to a friend of mine
uh who wanted me some cash what else
1500 uh 1500 to a friend okay and your
and your check at the end of the month
is going to be what 10 grand five eight
grand
roughly it fluctuates between about 8
500 so yeah so you're gonna be able to
clear up almost everyone but the big one
and your car and by Christmas the big
one and the car are going to be cleared
up no debt you feel the chaos leaving
your life feel the order happening
this is what we're doing very precise
follow this exactly hold on we're gonna
get you with a counselor in your area a
financial coach we're going to furnish
it free we want to be part of you
changing your life young man hold on
foreign
[Music]
anxiety weighs down the heart but a kind
word
cheers it up
Cory ten Boom said
God takes our sins the past present and
future and dumps them in the sea and
puts up a sign that says no fishing
allowed
oh you gotta love Corey open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Elise is in Phoenix hi Elise
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi gentlemen thank you for taking my
call today sure how can we help
so my husband and I are currently on
baby step two
um we have roughly paid off about 40
Grand since 2020 while also cash flowing
a wedding a bachelor's degree and a
high-risk pregnancy and we have about
eighteen thousand dollars left y'all
been busy
yeah uh since having our son in November
we have had a whirlwind of the year
um we lost my mother-in-law to cancer in
March we lost my grandfather in June and
we lost my husband's grandmother on
Monday oh my goodness
wow yeah
so um we've been handling my
mother-in-law's estate there was no will
or trust so we've been hunting down
individual accounts with my husband and
his brother listed his beneficiaries and
we're starting to receive some of that
money
um we've been treating our situation as
a combination of storm mode along with
baby step two
um because you never know as like her
medical bills and things are going to
come in so we're trying to make sure
that we have a stash set aside you're
not you're not liable for her medical
bills okay good
um her estate is
yeah the money that's in her name has to
be used for those before you get to take
it as heirs but uh but you can't Europe
not personally liable for her medical
bills
no we're just the ones that are handling
that yeah so you don't need a storm mode
because your personal finances aren't
affected by her situation beautiful so
that was my first question because we
have we received an annuity from her and
currently a thirty one thousand dollars
in the bank and that would take that was
a benefit you were the beneficiary of
the annuity
yes okay that's your money that's clear
of the estate you don't have to worry
about it
so we can go ahead and use that for baby
step two and you can use that for
anything you want to personally
awesome
um so we'll probably handle that today
um the second step we just transferred
about seventy seven thousand dollars in
single stocks into our names and then we
have an inherited IRA and an inherited
401K that will be split between my
husband and his brother once we're ready
for it
um with losing everyone we're just
trying to cling to stability and so what
we were wondering is if it was a wise
decision to liquidate some of those
single stocks for a good down payment on
a house next year
um I think you're too much in the middle
of the fire to worry about a house right
now don't do anything I think right now
you just can't clean up and get to calm
clean up and get to get to sit and then
just sit in this a little while probably
next year if you have extra money above
your emergency fund and you're 100 debt
free we'll talk about a house yeah
that's probably exactly
but please please please please please
don't spend money that you don't have
yet and even these inherited whatevers
if she's got bills to pay you're gonna
have to go to pay off the off the estate
and you're going to feel like these
companies stole from you they didn't
they just need their payment let me let
me stop you a second okay there's two
categories of money in her estate
okay there's stuff that named you a
beneficiary if there's life insurance
and you're a beneficiary your husband
that comes straight to you that is not
in her estate that annuity comes
straight to you as a beneficiary it's
not in her estate those stocks
are not yours
that checking account even if your
husband's name on it is not yours that
money has to be used to pay her medical
bills
okay before you clear up anything
okay perfect so unless it came to you
and it caused it was in or your husband
because it was in a named beneficiary it
has to be used to pay the bills of the
estate now an inherited IRA did it have
a named beneficiary on it
yes okay
same thing then that is outside of the
estate it is not subject to her other
bills but that stock you're talking
about those checking accounts those are
you got to keep that separate over to
the side until the bills are cleared
okay you see the difference
yes because those weren't in your name
the other the other stuff was named
directly not you your husband named
directly to him so um I think it's going
to be worth your all's while to spend
500 or a thousand dollars with a with a
probate attorney to help you sort
through this and do this properly
because you're gonna have to file some
of this stuff with the judge
okay and uh you're gonna you shouldn't
be a huge attorney's fee I wouldn't pay
much more than that but 500 a thousand
bucks should get that probated and you
know get the stuff transfer was there a
car as an example
yes yeah so you can't transfer that
title without without a court order
okay so because you can't sign her name
she's dead right you have to sign you
have to sign on behalf of her and the
court has to give you permission to do
that so
yeah you guys need to get an attorney
and that'll help you separate the things
we're talking about but When the Smoke
Clears on this if the medical bills
aren't too high it sounds like you're
going to be debt free with a nice Nest
Egg above your emergency fund and yes
maybe this time next year I'm going to
be thinking about uh or after the first
of the year I'm going to be thinking
about getting a car or getting a house
rather and being debt free and having
the emergency fund in place before you
do any of that good question did God
help any listener
who doesn't have a will yes gosh get a
will get a will get a will get a will it
does not increase your probability of
death
no but it is not going to make any
you're not gonna make it you're gonna
die you need a will go to mama bear
legal forms and get a will go to a local
state planning attorney get a will but
somewhere get you a will you're not that
expensive it's not that complicated
um yes it's weird talking about dying
but guess what you're gonna die I'll
help you with it you're not gonna make
it get a will
please save all this Pro listen listen
to that sweet girl lost three family
members in the period of just a short
few weeks and now has to deal with this
with and doesn't they're out like a
treasure hunt looking for accounts
when they should be sitting on the front
porch hugging each other telling stories
about how much they loved you yeah and
instead yeah they're combing through
your stuff
detector in the backyard looking for the
coffee can where you hid the money
could will get a will
wow it's bad
huh and right before you get a will get
a budget
that was a bad segue but yeah maybe one
of the worst Segways ever ever ever ever
ever ever hey we're doing a free every
dollar budgeting webinar with Rachel
Cruz August 15th next week if you want
to watch this webinar with Rachel
teaching you how to run the every dollar
software the every dollar app properly
with an irregular income working the
baby steps in great detail she's going
to do that it's completely free Jade did
one yesterday with ten thousand people
in attendance it was pretty amazing
so Rachel's is next
um Tuesday I guess it is August 15th
whatever that is it's two that's that's
right Tuesday I think anyway August 15th
next week uh for most of you listening
go to everydollar.com budgeting and you
can sign up for this free webinar and uh
get get get the every dollar app start
working because every dollar is by far
the best budgeting app out there not
there's not even close second I know
people think about this or that let me
just tell you then we've got tens of
millions of people doing this so be sure
to check this out and if you need help
like I said ten thousand were with Jade
yesterday we can handle it August 15th
we're gonna have some more scheduled
over the next 60 days with George and
Rachel and Jade but this coming week is
Rachel August 15th everydollar.com
budgeting and um
that'll get you going for sure without a
doubt so uh Dr John deloney good show
today thank you so the I guess the the
key takeaways are
pre-buy my book
get a will
get every dollar app foreign
people think John deloney that's the
next word they think that's what they
think Austin Ben James Zach and Andrew
are in the booth the booth dudes did a
great job today I'm Dave Ramsey your
host will be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started